from today granting clemency to some
high-profile figures including commuting
the sentence of Rob Blagojevich the
former Illinois governor we're serving
the eighth year of a 14-year prison
sentence for trying to sell President
Obama's Senate seat among other things
president Trump also pardoning former
New York police commissioner Bernie
Kerik who served three years in federal
prison after he pleaded guilty to tax
fraud and lying to the government here's
a president earlier we have commuted the
sentence of Rod Blagojevich he served
eight years in jail is a long time to go
many people disagree with a sentence
he's the Democrat he's not a Republican
it was a prosecution by the same people
Comey Fitzpatrick the same group there
was a tweet of course from Bernie
Sanders he said today Trump granted
clemency to tax cheats Wall Street
crooks billionaires and corrupt
government officials meanwhile thousands
of poor and working-class kids sit in
jail for nonviolent drug convictions
this is what a broken and racist
criminal justice system looks like so
I'm sure this is going to be a topic
tomorrow at the debate maybe what you
could do from the legal point of view
emily is explain to people the
difference between a commutation and a
pardon a pardon expunges the conviction
altogether and a commutation just
reduces the sentence usually to time
served so basically you're free to go
but you will still have that conviction
a pardon is you are no longer a
convicted felon it's interesting you
know Bernie Sanders those having that we
have such an issue with that because
he's been a legislator for a long time
and he has had plenty of years to work
on and be a leader for legislative
reform in the criminal justice system so
the notion that president Trump waving a
wand is so abhorrent to these people
that have had all the power within them
this entire time for someone who does
spend a lot of time in prisons and with
inmates and with convicted felons I
think that's all wrong well during
Barack Obama's tenure I have to bring
President Obama back well it's
presidents week so why not he did
initiate a lot of reforms in the
criminal justice system to reduce
sentences especially for nonviolent
offenders and I'm proud of the work that
he did in that area Eric Holder was a
leader and Bernie Sanders did embrace
that I wanted to say the President did
release two nine
individuals today similar to Alice
Johnson so that's a good thing but the
problem with commuting or pardoning
people like the former governor we have
too many corrupt elected officials in
this country too many people who are
still still in taxpayers money
you just have to google it I started
googling it just came up from every
region of the country and I think to
part in individuals like the governor it
sends a bed well the governor
Blagojevich were talking in the break
that was a huge story at that time
remember I was like wait he did what he
called Dubois and then there was the
attempted extortion of the Children's
Hospital and other things for personal
gain like that was at the time kind of
the definition of the swamp yeah you try
to sell a Senate seat and then got
caught yeah I think he probably got his
sentence commuted because he was on
Celebrity Apprentice
everybody knows probably it's a personal
connection but 14 years for trying to
sell a Senate seat it's a little much I
would have given him a little bit less
but that's neither here nor there Bernie
Kerik had renovations done to his
apartment in exchange for a political
favor and then lied about it he's
supposed to get two years according to
the guidelines he gets four I mean the
guy's a patriot he made a really bad
judgment it just seems like an
overzealous sentence in prosecution but
if you look at when the left gets upset
I mean there was that five-time illegal
alien felon who murdered Kate Steinle
and he gets nothing and the left was
cheering they were clapping and now
these guys get commutations or whatever
after taught a lot of time served and
they're saying this is a grave
miscarriage of justice I mean do these
help Trump politically not really are
they as bad as when Bill Clinton pardons
the largest tax cheat what u.s. history
or the porter recant about do you think
Greg is Lagos second act here getting a
second chance here come out and do have
you seen him he looks great
his fit he's got this incredible wavy
white hair that prison because I think
is gonna do these sexy grandfather
calendar 2021 I don't think to your
point though this doesn't fit the
mission of draining the swamp
Blagh
one of the worst kind of swamp swamp
rats he was selling a seat and we did
that story here this before you were
here Jesse
so you're exempt but I mean we talked
about a lot what he that what a crook he
was and how bad it was and that's why
it's like it's not something I agree
with
it's not something I care too much about
I would prefer to see other people more
deserving of commutation there must be
but is it a zero no the San Francisco
49ers you know I'm a 49er fan so that's
okay no that's okay Louisiana and
getting bribes one more that's a bad
sick Michael the Michael Milken one so
he was involved in the drunk bond
trading stuff since then when he got out
he has done a lot of philanthropy true
a.m. prostate cancer is try to like work
his way up out of that hole there are
worse things and when you don't
prosecute someone like McCabe who lies
under oath four times to federal agents
or you don't nail Hillary for
obstruction after she acid washes 30,000
emails under subpoena those are the kind
of things that people get really angry
about Bernie Kerik who's already served
this time you get angry at a president
that's trying to solicit you know dirt
from a foreign country army and so
almost president Hillary quit and
Hillary we further impeach